kait parker asks Gary I am growing my
business and looking to include partners
for content what's the best way to
recruit them money promise of exposure
okay I'm super pumped guys I went to
high school okay by the way let me give
a big shout out to Kate Kate came to my
high school junior year of high school
in the middle of the year and Kate was a
top five attractive Grom being very
politically correct dear in our school
she made huge noise Kate huge shout out
for the noise you made it North
Hunterdon high school 1993 and recruited
like as a soccer star by the way just
give me some defs Kate Kate I you know
I've been noticing a lot of somebody
works incredible by the way it's been
really fun to watch anyway um you know I
think both work right it depends what
people are motivated by if you have a
big enough platform to create exposure
people will work for free d rock hit me
up and offer to make a film for free for
me because he knew that was going to get
him his exposure hee hee hee vetted or
intuitively felt I was a good guy sure
enough before I gave him a full time job
offer to work here which think about
that outcome but let's that's for
another day he did get into contact with
Chris he'll be here d Rock Brogan Ted
really i mean like so so he made the
right move right like you could say wow
he did that for free the reason I'm
always willing to take free work and
free hustle is because I feel
comfortable with the fact that i'm going
to try to pay them back tenfold on the
ROI by giving them a shout out I know
other people that are marketing leaders
pay attention to me because I've been on
a cusp of doing new stuff and so he had
all those opportunities now I swooped in
and saw the raw amazing talent of this
man had and had to bring him on board
and this show exists because d-rock
joined the family and it gave me the
infrastructure something shout out to
you d Rock uh so I think free works if
you think other photographers will see
value in your platform or whatever
you're trying to accomplish money always
works as well and so you know I think
people motivated by different things you
know some people I'll tell you something
people always try to do with me I never
do it but people do it all the time is
leveraging your rolodex I mean the
amount of people that are willing to do
things for me for me to get them to
people I don't you know i'm not gonna
name-drop but like it's insane I never
want to do that because I think that's
not doing the right thing for my
relationship but I understand why people
do what people do it to me left them
right the amount of like hey Gary do you
mean my boy Johnny McGee and I when I
meet you at eb games like yeah I gave
Ricky McGee a billion dollars to get to
you like it happens all time joy people
value different things I think money and
exposure are two things that actually
that are we doing Patriots tough guys
you understand I'm a weird gut guys I'm
a weird guy I'm weird I will fire over
crazy weird [ __ ] many I'm not scared
about this I'm not scared mini I fire
over Patriots yet I promise um hey guys
how about how do you like this what
about this like that so yeah that's it
let's go on the next question oh crap
wait subscribe do I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe